think that it's so easy to fall into a
job just for the paycheck but for us we
look for kindness as well as the desire
to really create an impact on society
i'm trisha vantig i'm the ceo and
co-founder of queenly and i'm 27 years
old
so we built queenly and it's an online
marketplace dedicated towards the whole
formal wear industry and so we enable
women to be able to buy and sell dresses
from one another as well as for small
businesses that carry bridal dresses or
quinceanera dresses to come on board
online
i've been in the pageant industry for
about eight years now and towards the
end i just have been seeing this same
exact problem
not every girl comes from an affluent
family where you can afford a 700
dress like off the rack so that's what i
really thought about starting queenly
fundraising was very hard i'm not even
going to sugarcoat it especially one
were female founders two were
underrepresented like minority founders
three were selling dresses every single
meeting we walked into whether it's in
person or zoom we had to make sure we
brought our a plus plus game my
co-founder went to penn i went to
berkeley like these are great schools we
worked at uber facebook and pinterest
great companies still isn't enough when
we bring up hey we used to do pageants
hey we're tackling the dress industry
and so i think that we just have to work
twice three times as hard as male
founders in this industry
[Music]
i think the wonderful thing about our
company my co-founder and i and our team
is that
we're not just doing this for fun or
because we want to look cool as startup
founders we really care about
our users we care about changing this
industry keeping that in our hearts that
this is the goal we want to solve is we
want to empower all women to be able to
find their dream dress and to look and
feel like a queen that really grounds
all of us